landz und
[Musik]
Precht schönen guten Tag Richard hallo
Markus wir ziehen eine Folge vor weil es
viel Aufregung gab wir haben uns beim
letzten Mal und es wurde sehr sehr viel
gehört ich habe viele Rückmeldungen
bekommen von Leuten die sagten das war
spannend weil sehr lebensnah erzählt wir
haben jetzt mal ein bisschen besser
verstanden was Israel eigentlich ist und
wie kompliziert das dort alles ist wir
haben dann über orthodoxe und vor allen
Dingen über
ultraorthodoxe Juden
gesprochen und darüber gesprochen dass
es in der israelischen Gesellschaft
durchaus Diskussionen darüber gibt weil
die Frage im Raum steht wie sehr die
Ultraorthodoxen und nur über die haben
wir gesprochen bereit sind sozusagen
sich an an diesem israelischen Leben und
Alltag zu beteiligen da sind ein paar
Sätze gefallen die mindestens
missverständlich waren ich habe gesagt
da gibt es diese Menschen die meisten
von ihnen arbeiten nicht weil sie sich
wirklich vollumfänglich der Religion
widmen hätte auch sagen können viele von
ihnen arbeiten nicht dann hast du gesagt
sagt ja die dürfen gar nicht arbeiten
außer so ein paar Sachen wie
Diamantenhandel Finanzgeschäfte und so
weiter und das ist ihnen von der
Religion her
untersagt ich habe dem beigepflichtet
und das bezog sich aber auf die Sache
mit der Arbeit das andere habe ich
ehrlich gesagt an dem Moment weil wir
uns ins Wort gefallen sind gar nicht
mehr richtig wahrgenommen und war sehr
überrascht über die Heftigkeit dieser
Anwürfe und ich muss auch zugeben es hat
mich dann irgendwann an einem bestimmten
Punkt getroffen auch wenn es vor allen
Dingen dich erwischt hat es hat mich
getroffen dass du so in Windeseile und
ich nebenbei gleich mit zum Antisemiten
umetikettiert worden bist weil ich a aus
persönlichen Gesprächen weiß äh dass du
alles bist aber sicher kein Antisemit äh
und dass du publizistisch unheimlich
viel in dieser Richtung auch gemacht
hast gearbeitet hast viel darüber redest
und erzählst die die Schoa und alles was
damit zusammenhängt am herzensanlegen
ist immer gewesen bei mir das gleiche
ich habe immer wieder das haben uns
redaktionell immer wieder vorgenommen äh
die letzten Überlebenden immer wieder
versucht auch wenn es teilweise
wahnsinnig schwierig war ins Studio zu
holen ich habe eine Reportage gemacht
darüber du sollst leben was für mich in
in vielerlei Hinsicht äh ja der Dreh war
der mich hat verstehen lassen worum es
da eigentlich wirklich geht und wie tief
das alles geht auch über Generationen
hinweg und deswegen hat mich das
wirklich verletzt deswegen jetzt noch
mal dich die Frage dieser Einwurf so von
der von der Seitenlinie war das ja
wirklich bin ja ins Wort gefallen an der
Stelle du sagtest sie dürfen gar nicht
arbeiten außer so ein paar Sachen wie
Diamantenhandel Finanzgeschäfte
ausgenommen ist ja grundsätzlich von der
Religion her untersagt ja das ist falsch
also das ist falsch
das war so salop daher geredet und das
entspricht einfach nicht den Fakten die
ganze der ganze Sachverhalt ist deutlich
komplizierter zunächst mal möchte ich
mich für allen entschuldigen die darin
etwas antisemitisches gesehen haben denn
Antisemitismus ist mir so fern also wie
kaum irgendetwas anderes ich habe mich
durchaus mit dem orthodoxen Judentum
beschäftigt das fing schon an als ich 12
13 war da habe ich die Bücher von Harry
kemelmann gelesen harry kemelmann war so
ein Erfolgsschriftsteller der ist ein
Held ein Rabbi war und da wo es dann um
die jüdische Gemeinde ging in einem Band
auch um Israel und um die Orthodoxen und
so weiter ich fand das immer wahnsinnig
faszinierend ich habe dann später mich
auch mit der Geschichte des Judentums
beschäftigt ich hatte nämlich
ursprünglich vor nicht über Musil
sondern über sie Fred
Krakauer der seiner Satz jüdisch ist zu
promovieren und da kommt isidur Krakauer
der Onkel vor und der hat eine
zweibändige Geschichte der Juden in
Frankfurt geschrieben und die habe ich
auch komplett gelesen das heißt also
mich hat dieses Thema sehr interessiert
und das letzte Glied wo es mich
interessiert hat war nachdem meine
Lebensgefährtin unorthodox gelesen hatte
von Debora Feldmann und da sind wir dann
tatsächlich kurz dar drauf nach
Williamsburg fahren äh zur satma
Gemeinde die dort ist die äh zu den
richtig großen Ultraorthodoxen Gemeinden
gehört und wir waren im letzten Herbst
äh im Dezember in Antwerpen über meinen
Geburtstag hinweg und haben uns dort den
Diamantenhandel angeguckt so und weil
ich mich damals beschäftigt habe wovon
lebt die satm Gemeinde wie muss man sich
das vorstellen ähm wie wie wie sind da
genau die Regeln wer arbeitet und wir
nicht und so weiter deswegen habe ich
das so lapida eingeworfen was falsch
daran ist ist natürlich das war mir im
grundommen auch klar natürlich kein
religiöses Gebot gibt nicht arbeiten zu
dürfen sondern dass das quasi freiwillig
geschieht es kann auch kein religiöses
Gebot geben dass den Diamantenhandel
erlaubt waril das Quatsch war weil D zu
in torzeiten gab's gar kein
Diamantenhandel also das war jetzt keine
Aussage äh die richtig formuliert war
sondern die war in der Form falsch
formuliert weil man dann den Eindruck
kriegen würde es gibt sozusagen
religiöses Gebot der Finanzgeschäfte
sind okay und die handandel ist okay und
sonst ist Arbeiten nicht okay also wenn
man das so so auslegt und so klang der
Satz ja muss man auch einfach sagen dann
ist der Quatsch ne und den müssen wir
jetzt mal ein bisschen auseinandernehmen
der Hauptgrund warum die Juden nicht
gearbeitet haben und das weiß man ich
meine im oberstufenunterricht in der
Schule lernt man das aber ich habe das
auch in Buch Isidor Krakauer sehr genau
alles verfolgt ist natürlich dass sie
ausgeschlossen waren aus den zümften aus
den Gilden äh im Mittelalter
dass sie dass sie aus den Handwerks
Berufen rausgedrängt oder gar nicht
zugelassen worden sind und dass sie dann
ausgewichen sind in mehrere Tätigkeiten
unter anderem in Finanzgeschäften das
alles war mir klar aber wir haben ja an
dieser Stelle auch keine lange
Auseinandersetzung über das orthodoxe
Judentum gemacht sondern ich habe das so
lax da eingeworfen gerade noch weil ich
unter diesen Eindrücken Diamantenhandel
anwerpben und diese Williamsburg wo ich
war weil ich das noch im Kopf hatte und
mir irgendwie klar war sehr viele Männer
die ultraorthodox sind Arbeiten nicht
aber diese Tätigkeiten da gibt's den ein
oder anderen der dem nachgeht so das ist
der historische Sachverhalt von mir in
der Form durch die Verkürzung falsch und
schief dargestellt würd gerne einmal da
kurz einhaken Richard
ähm du hast etwas gesagt an dem Punkt
völlig ohne bösen Hintergedanken und
genauso habe ich das auch so halb
wahrgenommen wie gesagt ich ich ich habe
es in dem Moment gar nicht richtig
verstanden weil ich schon beim nächsten
Gedanken war aber als ich dann in der in
der in der rezitierung D noch mal
gelesen habe dachte ich okay richard
hatte keinen bösen Hintergedanken dabei
du hast ja gerade erklärt warum du das
im Kopf hattest ich verstehe vollkommen
wenn man zu einem Punkt kommt dem man
sagt okay das rührt jetzt oder ist ganz
ganz nah dran an Feldern die in dem
Zusammenhang nichts zu suchen haben ne
die die die die Nazis der der die die
großen Verschwörungstheorien die die
rotschilds all diese Dinge diese ganzen
üblen Begrifflichkeiten das ist da nah
dran und zu nah dran
und und es man macht das gerade in
diesen Zeiten ist ist das mehr als
unglücklich und das kann man stark
kritisieren und und ist auch völlig in
Ordnung du hast natürlich völlig recht
ja das ist hochgradig vermientes terr ja
da es eben ja diese Jahrhunderte alte
und von den Nazis ganz besonders
vergiftete Tradition gibt hier etwas
absolut pejoratives draus zu machen ja
und absolutesten Antisemitismus mit Geld
verdienen und Finanzgeschäften und so
weiter zu verbinden ist das natürlich
unglücklich gewesen dass man ebeno
lapidar da rein zu sagen ja das ist
völlig richtig und all die Menschen die
religiöse Gefühle ich damit verletzt
habe oder die sich verzerrt dar gestellt
gesehen haben oder die das an
antisemitische Klischees erinnert hat
bei denen entschuldige ich mich ganz und
gar denn nichts liegt mehr ferner als
irgendetwas in diese Richtung von mir zu
geben zumal es sich n wirklich nicht
immer im Kopf me findet so und der
zweite Teil grundsätzlich Arbeiten von
der Religion her untersagt ja und und da
wird sehr interessant ähm du sagst da in
an an dem Punkt dürfen gar nicht
arbeiten ist iH von der Religion her
grundsätzlich verboten ist ein bisschen
richtig muss man sagen und auch ein
bisschen falsch ja ist in der Form
falsch ja ich äh hab
heute mit Debora Feldmann die du gerade
zitiert hast die diesen weltbestzeller
unorthodox geschrieben hat noch mal
genau zu dem Thema telefoniert und sie
hat mir dann was geschickt und das fand
ich sehr sehr hilfreich muss einmal kurz
sagen Debora Feldmann war schon mehrfach
bei mir in der Sendung ist eine Frau die
in einer Ultraorthodoxen Gemeinde in
Williamsburg aufgewachsen ist genau da
wo Du warst das ist das Buch auf das du
anspielst dieser Weltbestseller und ist
eine Geschichte die an wirklich zutiefst
bewegt weil sie darin beschreibt wie man
mitten in diesem ja ich meine
ultraliberal New York ja wo alles geht
und Tag und Nacht alles offen ist und so
weiter leben kann wie in einer völlig
anderen Welt und und zwar ohne Zäune
drumrum sondern einfach nur weil man
sozusagen emotional sie drückt es immer
so aus emotional gekarert wird ja und
das ist etwas was mich damals wahnsinnig
beeindruckt hat sie ist
zwangsverheiratet worden musste einen
Mann heiraten den sie nicht geliebt hat
der aus dieser Gemeinde kam und hat sich
dann irgendwann musste sich die Haare
abrasieren und so weiter ja das
beschreibt sie alles in diesem Buch und
irgendwann hält sie es nicht mehr aus
und flieht aus New York und kommt nach
Berlin mit ihrem Sohn lebt auch
mittlerweile in Berlin ist eine
beeindruckend kluge Frau die in einer
wahnsinnig kurzen Zeit perfekt Deutsch
gelernt hat was für ihre unglaubliche
Intelligenz spricht mir das beeindruckt
das immer Debora Feldmann sagt es ist
grundsätzlich so dass es kein
Arbeitsverbot gibt bei orthodoxen
modoxuden gehensätzlich arbeiten aber
jetzt kommt bei den
Ultraorthodoxen ist die Einstellung zur
Arbeit ausschließlich
überlebensbedingt dient also dem Ziel
des notwendigen Unterhalts ja ist aber
nicht zur eigenen Bereicherung oder dem
Genuss irdischer Dinge vorgesehen und
deshalb sagt sie wird nur so viel Arbeit
geleistet die genau dafür ausreicht
alles andere wird als problemat beugt
weil zu viel sozusagen weltliche Arbeit
auf Kosten der spirituellen Arbeit gehen
kann hab mit ein Verbot zu tun sondern
mit einer Selbstverpflichtung mit einer
Selbstverpflichtung und diese aber die
gelebte Wirklichkeit ist das was was
sozusagen ein ein sekularer Israeli als
als als Arbeit versteht das versteht
eben der ultraorthodoxe nicht so und der
sieht das anders der wird auch das was
er macht die spirituelle Arbeit als
Arbeit ansehen aber es ist nicht
sozusagen das gleiche und das ist
wichtig das mal zu zu verstehen und sie
sagt spirituelle Arbeit wird in der
ultraorthodoxen Welt als erstrangig
betrachtet und alle weiteren Arbeiten
die von dieser wichtigen Leistung
ablenken könnten brauchen eine klare
Rechtfertigung um ausgeführt zu werden
ja mm und jetzt kommt der Punkt da es in
modernen Demokratien sagt sie oft
Sozialhilfe gibt sehen sich
ultraorthodoxe zum ersten Mal mit der
Schwierigkeit konfrontiert eine irdische
Arbeit religionsbedingt als unerlässlich
einzuordnen denn wenn sie ausfällt folgt
nicht mehr unbedingt die Hungersnot ja
die in der Vergangenheit diese irdische
Tätigkeit hätte rechtfertigen können
also durch die Sozialhilfe in Israel
schreibt sie ist der minimale
Lebensunterhalt gesichert von daher
unterscheiden sich Teile der
ultraorthodoxen Welt für das religiöse
Studium weil sie eben nicht mehr
argumentieren können dass die Arbeit
über lebensnotwendig wäre das ist
interessant Frauen übrigens sind davon
ausgenommen die können in den meisten
Fällen in bestimmten und in als
sichergeltenden Bereichen arbeiten wenn
es die familienversorgung zulässt und
dann noch ein letzter Punkt für Juden
schreibt sie haben die Tätigkeiten im
Diamantenhandel und in der
Finanzwirtschaft eine lange Tradition
denn aufgrund des bekannten
arbeitsverbots hast du gerade zitiert im
Mittelalter waren sie gezwungen in
diesen wenigen Bereichen zu arbeiten und
sich dadurch auszuzeichnen und da s
schon seit Generationen darin verwurzelt
sind ergibt sich natürlich eine
Expertise die die weitere Ausübung
dieser Tätigkeiten nachvollziehbar
unterstützt und letzter Satz um auch den
nicht zu unterschlagen heute arbeiten
sagt sie orthodoxe sowie Teile der
ultraorthodoxen in allen möglichen
berufswäern aber eben auch in den so
viel dazu das ist eine absolut
tiefgehende gründliche Analyse für das
was ich in einem Satz schief und
missverständlich dargestellt habe weißt
du die Frage der Intention Richard ne
ich ich habe viel nachgedacht am
Wochenende darüber ich weiß nicht ob du
das mitgekriegt hast und es war genau
die Sendung mit Debora Feldmann und
krigor Gesi und Manfred Lütz in der wir
über Religion gesprochen
haben in der etwas passiert ist was in
diesem Zusammenhang auch sehr
interessant
ist mitten in dieser Sendung Grigor Gesi
holt geradeaus benutzt er plötzlich ein
Wort das man wirklich nicht mehr
benutzen sollte er benutzt das
sogenannte n Wort und ich dachte ich
höre nicht richtig
was hat er da jetzt gesagt und frag nach
weil es mir natürlich aufgefallen ist
und sagt Gisi war das ein Zitat und an
der Antwort habe ich gemerkt er versteht
eigentlich gar nicht was ich meine er
war sich überhaupt nicht darüber im
Klaren was er gerade gesagt hatte und
dann habe ich in dieser Situation kurz
sehr intensiv gegrübelt und habe dann zu
dem Kunstgriff gegriffen und habe gesagt
okay sie haben jetzt jetzt etwas gesagt
sagt und ich könnte sie jetzt dafür
aufspießen aber ich tue das nicht weil
ich weiß wer vor mir sitzt deswegen habe
ich es nicht getan weil ich wusste da
sitzt Gregor Gesi den ich ein bisschen
kenne den ich auch privat ein kleines
bisschen ab und zu mal erlebt habe und
von dem ich weiß dass er niemals in
seinem Leben durch rassistische oder
antisemitische oder irgendwelche anderen
Äußerungen und Vorurteile unangenehm
aufgefallen ist in seinem ganzen
politischen Leben sicherhe kein Mens der
SAS denkt ja Gegenteil absolut im
Gegenteil steht für die genau
gegenteilige Position so und es wäre so
leicht gewesen einen riesenkandal zu
provozieren es wäre unendlich leicht
gewesen und durch diesen kleinen
Kunstgriff dadurch dass ich das erklärt
habe und kontextuisiert habe und gesagt
habe da ist ihn jetzt was rausgerutscht
aber es sagte jemand von dem ich mir
ganz ganz sicher bin da ist ih wirklich
jetzt eine Formulierung verrutscht ja
will ich ihm das nicht weiter übel
nehmen und die Reaktion war sehr
interessant es gab da die eine oder
andere Kritik aber gemessen an dem was
hätte sein können war es geradezu ein
laues Lüftchen es ist eigentlich nichts
passiert und das ist das du hast es
runtergekocht auf das was es war ja eine
missglückte Formulierung die die keine
abwertende sein sollte ne und die da im
Eifer des Gefechts ih da irgendwie
rausgerutscht ist weil man das Wort
früher häufiger verwendet hat und der
hat sich in dem Moment da keine Gedanken
drum gemacht und das bedeutet ja was du
gemacht hast du hast den Kontext
betrachtet du hast gesagt welche Person
sagt das und warum sagt sie das und wir
haben halt das große Problem in unserer
Medienlandschaft Dinge zu
dekontextualisieren ja um sie an den
prangern zu stellen also etwas völlig
aus dem Zusammenhang zu reißen um dann
eine Gesinnung oder sowas daran
festmachen zu wollen und ich meine das
ist eine Unsitte die die ist sehr sehr
verbeitet die hat ja nicht nur was mit
uns oder mit mir zu tun sondern die
trifft ja ganz häufig und ganz viele
Menschen und das ich denke mir immer das
ist eine eine Art der Kultur wie wir
nicht miteinander umgehen sollten ich
meine gerade in diesen Tagen kommt mal
der vierte Band meiner
Philosophiegeschichte raus mehr als die
Hälfte der dort ausgesprochen liebevoll
ja vorgestellten analysierten
betrachteten philosophierten Philosophen
und Denker Sigmund Freund Henri bergon
Edmund hussall Siegfried Krakauer Ernst
Bloch Georg lukatch Walter Benjamin sind
jüdisch Martin Buber ja und die werden
hier liebevoll erklärt dargestellt ihre
Bedeutung herausgearbeitet ich meine
welcher Antisemit würde sowas tun und
ich unterscheide noch einmal in aller
Deutlichkeit ja wenn jemand von der
jüdischen Botschaft denkt oh guck mal
hier da taucht diese Schablone auf die
ist antisemitisch die darf hier nicht in
der Öffentlichkeit stehen bleiben dann
hat das seine volle Berechtigung du
siehst ja die USA du siehst wohin das
führt du siehst auch andere Länder und
ich ich denke da manchmal okay wenn wir
heute schon so miteinander reden heute
so so schnell den Stab brechen
und und und Leuten dann irgend wirklich
die die heftigsten Vorwürfe machen ohne
sie jemals selber auch mal dazu angehört
zu haben z.B und in 10 Jahren werden wir
dann da sitzen und werden die die Gräben
beklagen die auf diese Art und Weise
durch diese Art und Weise des Diskurses
entstanden sind und werden uns
fassungslos ansehen und fragen wie
konnte uns das passieren und ich glaube
das sollte man ernsthaft verhindern und
wenn man Gräben sagt muss ich jetzt noch
mal an dem Punkt bora Feldmann zitieren
die sagt wir reden bei Israel immer über
Feinde von außen aber im Prinzip geht es
eigentlich auch um Feindschaft von innen
ja die Feindschaft von innen hat diese
Situation herbeigeführt und auch die
Situation das sagt sie so schlimm
eskalieren lassen und umgekehrt gibt das
eben die Situation auf der anderen
Seite alle jungen Palästinenser ja die
ich erlebt habe und das bestätigt auch
jemand wie wie Debora Feldmann das sind
ganz oft Menschen die mit iion an sich
wenig zu tun haben also das heißt dieses
Bild der der komplett
radikalisierten palästinensischen Welt
das ist so auch in keinster Weise
zutreffen sondern diese jungen Leute
sind ganz häufig mit ihren Vertretungen
ihren politischen Vertretungen
wahnsinnig unzufrieden aber sie haben
ganz selten die Chance irgendetwas zu
verändern weil auch diese Gewalt ja den
Erfolg dieser terroristischen
Organisationen befeuert und wenn man
sich D das Regime der heramas in in in
Gaza auch anguckt ich meine es gab nach
dem einen Wahlsieg danach wurde auch nie
wieder gewählt gab es ja mal dann auch
Aufstände und da hat man dann zur
Abschreckung einfach Leute von
Hochhäusern geworfen um klar zumachen
wer hier das Sagen hat und und das ist
auch der Grund warum man wenn man in die
palästinensischen Gebiete reist und ich
war da wirklich öfter in den letzten
Jahren du hast da da liegt immer so eine
eine eine Traurigkeit eine Melancholie
darüber das ist ähm du hast das Gefühl
das ist ein ein ein gedemütigtes Volk
und es gibt gerade für die jungen Leute
es gibt keinen guten Weg nach draußen
und die junge Israelis auf der anderen
Seite die empfinden das genauso und
wandern mittlerweile es bestätigt auch
auch Debora Feldmann wandern reihweise
wandern aus die gehen weg weil sie diese
zunehmende Radikalisierung wo Religion
eine große große Rolle spielt und
benutzt wird auf beiden Seiten weil sie
das dieses Klima tatsächlich nicht mehr
ertragen das ist die ganze Tragödie
eigentlich gibt es auf beiden Seiten so
viele und die habe ich immer wieder
selber auch erlebt ganz vernünftige
Menschen die so genug haben von diesem
Blut vergießen und die das Gefühl von
Ohnmacht haben weil es Kräfte gibt die
immer wieder deutlich machen wir wollen
genau das nicht wir wollen wir wollen
diesen Frieden nicht und jetzt durch
durch das was D am am vergangenen
Wochenende passiert ist ist natürlich
also israel hat jedes Recht sich zu
verteidigen ja klar und wie wie soll man
miteinander reden wenn wenn wenn die
andere Seite so etwas macht wie soll das
gehen und trotzdem haben wir ja in der
letzten Folge das mit der Hoffnung
verbunden dass es nicht zu grausig wird
ne das Schicksal und die Folgen also das
Recht zu verteidigen stellt ja überhaupt
niemand in Abrede das ist
selbstverständlich da ja und auf der
anderen Seite ist eben die Frage was
wird ganz ganz genau passieren und das
scheint mir jedenfalls zum gegenwärtigen
Zeitpunkt noch ein bisschen unklar zu
sein und da bleibt ein ja nichts als die
Hoffnung damit zu verbinden dass das
keine unendliche Tragödie ist die das
als nächstes sich abzeichnet also man
man man hofft auf Besonnenheit und es
ist es ist 21 Jahrhundert ne es ist auch
die Macht der Information die Macht der
Bilder die Macht der Erzählungen die
Macht der narrative ich hatte dieser
Tage mehrfach Gelegenheit mit mit
deutschen Muslimen hier zu sprechen und
eine Frau sagte mir wortwörtlich sie
glauben doch nicht im Ernst dass das
unsere Leute waren sondern das ist
natürlich alles inszeniert
damit man einen Grund hat uns platt zu
machen und uns dem Erdboden gleich zu
machen und ich guckte sie völlig
fassungslos an und sagte sie glauben
jetzt nicht wirklich dass das inszeniert
ist sagte was denken sie denn
selbstverständlich dass das das erfahre
ich bei unseren Leuten das erzählen die
mir auch und und da wurde mir klar wenn
die das jetzt wirklich glaubt ja ja dann
dann kann das nur in der Totalen
Katastrophe enden ja also wir leben in
einem Jahrhundert wo Inus einer
unglaublichen Informationsfülle die
menschheitsgeschichtlich völlig neu ist
jeder sich am Ende seine Erzählung
raussucht die zu ihm passt und jeder am
Ende das glaubt was er glauben will und
das ist eine wirklich sehr sehr
gefährliche Entwicklung das ist nicht
nur dass man sich dann untereinander
nicht mehr verständigen kann erinnere
dich mal an die Diskussionen bei Corona
wie viele Freundschaften sind zerbrochen
in dieser Zeit wenn man plötzlich jeder
sich da sein Weltbild wie PIP
Langstrumpf macht und das geht ja jetzt
auch für das Beispiel was du gerade
erzählt hast genau das alles macht die
Sache nicht besser also früher waren
sehr viele Leute ebildet und heute haben
sehr viele Leute die Chance genutzt sich
selbst falsch und einseitig zu bilden
genau und deswegen noch mal Richard
abschließend gesagt ist es richtig uns
an dem Punkt zu kritisieren weil in
Zeiten wie diesen kann es keine
Zweideutigkeit geben wir müssen sauber
sein in der Information alles richtig
alles korrekt alles in Ordnung wir hab
mal gesehen wie wie Schwier ja und das
ist ja auch ich bin ja auch froh über
all die theologischen Kommentare die es
gegeben hat äh die das versucht haben
aufzudröseln und den historischen
Sachverhalt darzustellen das ist ja sehr
hilre genau das ist eine ziemlich
komplizierte Angelegenheit und so weiter
und das finde ich sehr gut und hilfreich
dass sie das gemacht haben was gelernt
was gelernt ja verlangen wir auch von
Politikern dass sie sich klar und sauber
äußern und sich dann im Zweifel auch
rechtfertigen wenn es daneben geht und
und entschuldigen wenn sich jemandes
Gefühle verletzt hab haben getan äh in
der Hoffnung dass es genauso angekommen
ist wie es gemeint war und noch ganz
schnell der Hinweis dass wir das jetzt
vorziehen bedeutet natürlich dass am
Freitag keine neue Folge unseres
Podcasts kommt
sondern erst am übernächsten Freitag
freue mich Dich dann zu hören Richard ja
ich mich auf dich tschüss Markus Tschüss
bis
bald eine Produktion von mhoch2 und
podstars bei OMR im Auftrag des
ZDF